RICHARD DOLAN: August 25,
1951, in Lubbock, Texas.
In the middle of the evening,
a lot of witnesses saw this.
Some of the key witnesses
were these professors
at Texas Technical
College, and they
see this pattern of lights.
It's like bluish-green, and it's
second a boomerang formation,
going right over them, silently.
And they are
astonished by what they
see there's no other way to put
this it just blew their minds.
The Lubbock case was
unusual because of the caliber
of the witnesses and their
academic credentials,
and I believe that's why the
case remained so prominent
in the [inaudible].
Fortunately, they were
photographed by a young man
named Carl Hart, who actually
took a series of photographs
that are very interesting and
have been studied quite a lot
by photo analysts
and UFO researchers.
Edward Ruppelt was brought in
to what was then called Project
Grudge in 1951, and they
come up with this explanation
that these lights were birds.
Late at night, getting
reflection off the underside
of their bellies by the
types of street lights,
or the lights that were made
in the city at the time.
The problem with that is
that there were many observers,
and they had seen birds before.
So the idea that those were
simply a flock of birds really
isn't a good explanation.
It could have been under
certain circumstances,
but in that particular setting,
it does not explain the data.